[Music]
what forgotten 2000's thriller starring
kevin costner was actually designed to
be a trilogy which of liam neeson's
action flicks would he like to take
another crack at how come the girls from
girls trip never went on a second trip
keep watching for the frustrating truth
by now the reputation of the unproduced
hellboy 3 is almost as enormous as the
movies that actually got made the story
for this potential feature was teased in
2008's hellboy 2 the golden army as the
titular superhero would have become an
apocalyptic threat to earth since then
the project has been discussed actively
by the hellboy creatives but it's never
materialized despite especially constant
encouragement from leading man ron
perlman in 2013 pearlman reaffirmed his
commitment by noting how enthusiastic he
was about director guillermo del toro's
vision for how hellboy's story would
wrap up the expansive scope of a
potential hellboy 3 may have excited
pearlman and del toro but it didn't do
much to convince potential financiers in
2017 del toro officially confirmed that
it was no longer happening with the
focus instead shifting onto a whole new
hellboy reboot that didn't involve any
of the creative participants of the
first two films though pearlman has
continued to beat the drum for hellboy 3
at least as recently as 2019 it doesn't
appear to be enough to actually get
anything off the ground
after years and years of dead ends will
ferrell and director adam mckay finally
delivered a second anchorman movie to
the world in december 2013. considering
they managed to turn one seemingly
impossible comedy sequel into a reality
once it's not inconceivable that they
could do it again with 2008's step
brothers and that movie's other leading
man john c reilly has been very open
about the fact that he's down for more
immature antics
in november 2018 he told good morning
america that there was a concept for a
second step brothers and that he was
hoping that it would materialize i mean
it requires the cooperation of a few
other people but i would love to do
another one of those yeah
this initially seemed like a promising
sign but in the years since there's been
no more word on this potential follow-up
in an even more discouraging sign riley
himself has downplayed the idea of it
ever becoming a reality in more recent
interviews part of the problem is simply
the busy schedules of everyone involved
especially mckay who's moved away from
bro comedies to more oscar-nominated
dramas and john c reilly has even more
important characters to play hi
i'm dr steve rule
edgar rice burroughs wrote several
novels chronicling the exploits of john
carter of mars back in the day so it
would make sense that he could also
spawn multiple big screen adventures
2012's john carter aimed to do just that
years later director andrew stanton even
revealed the logos and titles for two
sequels he'd once planned to helm and he
wasn't the only one who harbored
ambitions for more as leading man taylor
kitsch has also been eager to head back
to the red planet a few weeks after john
carter launched in theaters hitch made
it clear that he desperately wanted to
make another movie in this universe his
excitement for a sequel was also stoked
by the screenplay for the proposed
production unfortunately larger forces
beyond his control would ultimately make
this an impossibility john carter became
a legendary box office bomb as it lost
hundreds of millions of dollars for walt
disney pictures
any notions of a second film were
quickly scrapped despite kitsch's
enthusiasm so unlike the original
literary character the cinematic
incarnation of john carter will not go
on to have endless adventures the world
of speed racer is bursting with colors
and so many visual details that are
pretty much tailor-made to be explored
across multiple movies and the actors in
the 2008 big screen adaptation were
quite aware of this according to
christina ricci who played speed's
girlfriend trixie the entire cast was
yearning to go for another spin before
the movie even hit theaters as she told
coming soon.net in 2008 the wachowskis
created a world that they love and
created characters that they loved and
are attached to when we were all leaving
we were like write the sequel we want to
come back and they were like i know i
know we're going to don't worry they
were as sad for it to be over as we were
richie has maintained that commitment
towards a potential sequel well after
the movie's release in 2018 she
reaffirmed to cinema blend both her
affection for the wachowskis and her
continued desire to appear in a speed
racer follow-up but when the film zoomed
into theaters back in may of 2008
moviegoers at large didn't share
richie's enthusiasm the movie was a box
office dud as it lost enough money to
ensure that no warner brothers executive
would ever shout go speed racer go again
anytime soon
will smith hasn't packed his entire
career with endless sequels but he has
turned the likes of bad boys and men in
black into successful franchises his
2008 starring vehicle hancock seemed
poised to be his latest hit to land a
lucrative follow-up after all movies
about superheroes get sequalized all the
time true it may have been an original
story not based on a pre-existing comic
book but it did star will smith so why
should it be any different
by the end of 2008 smith expressed
excitement about what future hancock
movies could deliver and there seemed to
be plenty of potential in the ongoing
adventures of this tormented hero the
following year it looked like things
were heading in the right direction as
director peter berg revealed to mtv news
concrete details about the plot which
would be partially a prequel
alas a slew of factors began to prevent
hancock 2 from ever coming to life this
included smith's busy schedule which saw
him concentrating on other projects like
after earth and men in black three he
was still pitching new ideas for a
hancock sequel as recently as january
2012 but there haven't been any further
development since then
there's no shortage of adventures that
the four members of the a team could get
into in their days as tv superstars so
the 2010 big screen adaptation appeared
like it was also made to spawn a
franchise one of its stars was liam
neeson and considering that he returned
for multiple taken installments it
should come as no surprise that he was
open to the prospect of signing up
multiple follow-ups to the eight team as
well
as he told contact music in december of
2010 myself bradley cooper rampage
jackson and charlton copley are very
very keen to do it new york would be
cool and a couple of other countries too
maybe the cast may have been ready to go
but the a-team property turned out to be
less popular with moviegoers than it was
with tv viewers
in early 2011 neeson revealed to digital
spy that he was still eager to do
another movie with the original film's
cast and that 20th century fox hadn't
explicitly said no to the prospect of a
follow-up however he also noted that he
had a hunch that the box office results
weren't enough to justify financing a
sequel he turned out to be right on the
money a few years later director joe
carnahan officially confirmed that there
would be no sequel to the a-team no
matter how jazzed neeson may have been
judge dredd dished out some brutal
r-rated justice in the 2012 film dread
which managed to become a cult classic
and also helped kick-start the career of
alex garland who would go on to direct
ex-machina and annihilation despite such
notable accomplishments dread was still
a major box office disappointment thus
rendering any notion of a sequel quite
unlikely but the judged red character
has overcome significant odds before in
the comics so it's hardly surprising
that the actor who played him carl urban
was game to tackle the seemingly
impossible task of willing a sequel into
existence in may 2013 urban made his
passion apparent while also encouraging
fans to make their voices heard so while
there was a significant social media
response to make a dread sequel a
reality another movie never materialized
the closest fans ever got was an
announcement of a tv show that urban was
once in talks to headline but that also
never came to pass with years of radio
silence on the prospect of a dread 2 not
to mention urban now being busy starring
in amazon's the boys we don't imagine
justice will be served again anytime
soon
i'm the law
the candyman franchise has featured a
trio of sequels each of them involving
tony todd reprising his role as the
eponymous urban legend in some capacity
his enduring presence is a testament to
how much passion todd has for this
character and at one point the actor was
thoroughly committed to executing a new
kind of candyman sequel that would have
chronicled the title character trying to
make a go at life as a normal civilian
in a 2021 interview with bloody
disgusting todd shared details about
this sequel that he was hoping to get
off the ground it would feature candyman
trying to suppress his violent urges
while working as a professor at a new
england women's college living in an
environment full of women would have
been a challenge for the character and
the story would have also included a
tragedy that triggered the revival of
his old bee covered form todd was
excited for the project particularly the
striking visuals that were proposed at
the time issues having to do with which
studio owned the rights to the property
and who would get what amount of profits
halted the film from ever moving forward
those issues turned out to be too
insurmountable to overcome as this
particular sequel never became a reality
and we shall never be separated again
many successful comedies have gotten
sequels everything from caddyshack to
the hangover and even smaller money
makers like hot tub time machine have
been granted follow-ups considering this
phenomena it's puzzling how 2017's box
office hit girls trip has never managed
to score a sequel making this extra
puzzling is how tiffany haddish has
constantly talked about her excitement
on the prospect of taking another trip
in a 2020 interview with huffington post
the actress revealed that she and her
fellow leading ladies were dying to
reunite for a sequel but obstacles kept
getting in the way initially the problem
was the lack of a screenplay before the
primary issue then evolved into disputes
over the salaries for the leads
at the time of the interview haddish
said that she was still so excited to do
the sequel and that she was preparing to
pen a draft of the screenplay herself
there's clearly a lot of effort invested
in turning this project into a reality
but it remains to be seen if that will
be enough to overcome the problems that
have been encountered thus far
considering that it wasn't a massive box
office hit there's a good chance you've
never seen or even heard of the 2007
kevin costner serial killer thriller mr
brooks
nevertheless costner was game to
continue to explore the film's macabre
world across future adventures as mr
brooks was designed to spawn not just
one sequel but two as the actor revealed
to entertainment weekly this was written
with the idea that we would do a couple
of others when the writers first
presented the notion to me i said oh
bull i haven't done tin cup 2 or bull
durham 2 or open range the early years
so you don't have to try to hook me with
that but when they told me their idea
the hair on the back of my neck stood up
we're hoping this little movie develops
a following so we can play this story
out the way it should
costner may have been willing but the
box office returns were weak that lack
of receipts and the eventual financial
problems faced by distributor mgm
ensured that mr brooks would not be
getting a sequel let alone a trilogy
maybe it's more likely that tin cup 2
will eventually tee off
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you